as
mulheres em Steam Quais são as
dificuldades e as potencialidades
para apresentar este tema eu vou
apresentá-lo como a intersecção de duas
questões bastante atuais a calça
feminina e a educação e carreiras stem
a apresentar a causa Feminina eu vou
convidá-los a uma viagem no tempo
comecemos lá em 300 Anos Antes de Cristo
época mais ou menos de Alexandre o
Grande
consideremos uma velhinha de 50 anos de
idade
e ela já deveria se estivesse viva ela
teria um organismo debilitado
por causa de diversas gestações já não
teria força física e tudo sendo feito à
base de força física e muscular pouco
ela contribuiria a sociedade
continuamos a viagem chegamos a idade
média
aproximadamente
1.500 depois de Cristo
época das grandes navegações
esta mesma velhinha de 50 anos pouco
podia Como contribuir com suas com a
sociedade visto que tudo era feito à
base de força física
continuemos a viagem chegamos ao século
21 me permitam não mais celular esta
mulher de 50 anos de velhinha Hum será
que esta senhora 50 anos poderia estar
fazendo pesquisas e desenvolvimentos na
área de
estratégicas de defesa de um país me
parece que sim
com essa viagem ao longo do tempo
podemos ver a mudança radical na vida de
uma mulher de 50 anos
porém as mudanças na sociedade são muito
mais lentas do que as mudanças em casos
pontuais
na Roma antiga os homens tinham direito
de vida e morte sobre suas
esposas e filhos direito legal o mundo
mudou a sociedade Mudou as leis mudaram
porém Século 21 ainda vemos casos de
feminicídio homens matam suas
companheiras porque estas não querem se
submeter as suas vontades
já avançamos muito na causa feminina
porém ainda há muito o que fazer pela
Equidade de gênero
e vejamos a questão de educação stem e
carreras stemm stemm é uma sigla em
inglês
mundialmente conhecida para Ciência
Tecnologia Engenharia e matemática
e é comum em muitos países incluindo o
Brasil que os jovens não busquem é muito
as carreiras stem
é isso deve-se adversas fatores um dos
quais a educação de matemática no ensino
básico se de qualidade de baixa
qualidade com isso os jovens com uma
base não sólidas nas matemáticas passam
a considerar matemática e disciplinas
afins como
disciplinas difíceis E aí não buscam as
carreiras existem sendo assim um ensino
de qualidade de matemática nos anos
iniciais é de fundamental importância
para o desenvolvimento de um país
é mas Educação stem não é restrito às
disciplinas stem
educação stem é uma educação voltada
para desenvolver diversas habilidades do
Estudante através de atividades
multidisciplinares a educação stem em
geral é feita através de projetos
científicos desenvolvidos
é em trabalhos em equipes utilizando
recursos tecnológicos
e além das habilidades hard ou seja as
habilidades técnicas
e a educação stream desenvolve também
habilidades consideradas soft ou suaves
que são é trabalho em equipe
administração de tempo e de prioridades
comunicação para relatar os resultados
de seus projetos
em um mundo em que as profissões estão
em contínua modificação e transformações
essas habilidades devem ser devem estar
presentes em qualquer
Profissional não apenas os estendem as
carreiras System e são aquelas que
estarão envolvidas na
solução de quaisquer problemas que se
veia que se tenha em mente se você
pensar na democratização de ensino
monitoramento do meio ambiente poluição
a mobilidade urbana todos esses
problemas terão em sua solução
componentes estão sendo assim quanto
mais profissionais qualificados nestas
áreas
trabalhando com estes problemas mais
rápido teremos as soluções de Tais
questões
e vamos passar pela questão das mulheres
profissionais e
E aí mousse passam da mulher ou seja sua
saída do lar para assumir profissões
fora de casa deve ser muito a
conquistas devido às Ciências e
Tecnologias não fosse a pílula
anticoncepcional e os e Os
eletrodomésticos dificilmente as
mulheres poderiam sair de casa
é mas foi fácil Essa saída
as mulheres para iniciar em suas
carreiras profissionais em geral tiveram
que enfrentar diversos tipos de
dificuldades
entre eles dupla jornada de trabalho é a
responsabilidade com os filhos que ficam
quase que exclusivamente sobre as
mulheres
piadinhas sexistas visando diminuir suas
auto-confiança si mesmo Com todas essas
dificuldades
as mulheres conseguiram seus espaços nas
vidas profissionais olhamos ao redor e
vemos as mulheres com participação nas
mais diversas profissões
e como é a as mulheres como está a
participação das mulheres nas carreiras
stem bem nessas carreiras temos uma
disparidade muito grande entre homens e
mulheres
e por exemplo
mesmo em países ricos vou usar que os
Estados Unidos dados de 2011
e a distribuição de mulher entre
mulheres e homens nas carreira System
era de setenta e seis por cento de
homens versus 24 por cento apenas de
mulheres nas carreiras existem Se
considerarmos
todas as profissões essa distribuição é
de 52 por cento de homens enquanto 48
por cento de mulheres
e não se chegou ainda há uma
de alguma resposta de porque essa
disparidade
Mas será que isso é devido a sociedades
onde não existe igualdade de gênero
sociedades em que existe uma
desigualdade de gênero muito grande aí
entra o paradoxo Educacional da
igualdade de gênero
países com níveis elevados de igualdade
de gênero
apresentam uma apresentam uma
disparidade grande de mulheres em stem e
por exemplo
paraísos países considerados paraísos de
igualdade de gênero como Finlândia
Noruega Suécia tem menos de 25 por cento
de mulheres nas carreira System
e não existe uma resposta para essa
disparidade eu não como não existe não
vou ficar aqui discutindo
quais seriam essas causas mas vou
apresentar dois casos para as nossas
reflexões
e o número de mulheres em Ciências da
Computação
crescia mais do que o número de umas
e de repente esse número parou de
crescer e houve um declínio
e não existe uma solução única uma
resposta única para isso mas como
incidentemente isso aconteceu a partir
de
1984 quando começaram a aparecer os
computadores pessoais e estes como
brinquedos foram colocados nas
prateleiras de brinquedos para meninos
é um outro caso é o da engenheira deve
sterling formada por Stanford ela passou
por todas as dificuldades em sua
formação de engenharia ao final ela
percebeu que os seus colegas homens
tinham uma vantagem sobre elas durante a
sua em suas infâncias eles trabalharam
com brinquedos que desenvolviam
habilidades de visão tridimensional e de
coordenação motora de criação de
objetos e ela não então ela resolveu
apresentar um
uma desenvolver um brinquedo voltado
para desenvolver essas habilidades nas
meninas em busca de
financiamento Ela ouviu muitos não e
este brinquedo não é brinquedo de
meninas isto não vai vender Porque as
meninas não terão interesse nesse tipo
de brinquedo ela continuou com seu sonho
e lançou um brinquedo que é um sucesso
de venda e que está inspirando as
meninas as futuras engenheiras das
próximas gerações finalmente
o dado todo este contexto
estão se realizando as mais diversas
ações e
programas em todo o mundo visando
incentivar e despertar o interesse das
jovens meninas pelas carreiras e tem
aqui no ITA temos desde 2016 o projeto
um projeto voltado a esta questão
Olá neste projeto as nossas alunas de
graduação são as nossas embaixadoras
divulgando as a ideia de que carreira
System são sim carreiras de mulher
Oi e aí finalmente que deveremos
trabalhar todos juntos por esta causa
bem comecemos com as potencialidades das
carreiras e tem os problemas estão aí
para serem resolvidos as soluções
precisam de componentes existentes
quanto mais pessoas qualificadas
trabalhando nesses problemas mais rápido
chegaremos as suas soluções
sendo assim não podemos nos dar ao Luxo
de desperdiçar cinquenta por cento dos
cérebros como não aptos a trabalhar
nesses problemas esse cinquenta por
cento seriam os cérebros femininos
assim sendo avançar na causa feminina
diz principalmente despertando o
interesse das meninas pelas jovens
meninas pelas carreira System
e vai auxiliar assim encontrar mais
rápido as soluções de diversos problemas
que vão aumentar a qualidade de vida da
humanidade
e esta é uma causa pela qual se vale a
pena lutar